with all things considered i think it's
safe to say that the summer anime season
came back with a vengeance from
action-packed series romantic ventures
heart-wrenching dramas and light-hearted
comedies
this season has it all for you i'm not
even gonna talk about the sequels we all
know that this season is rife with
sequels of popular shows but for an
extra challenge i won't be talking about
them here after all my point is to show
that the season is such a strong one in
its own right so strap your seat belts
on and get ready to be amazed by the
various offerings that the anime
industry has given us
this season
so to start things off we go with japan
sings 2020.
it's been a while since we've been
treated with a grim disaster series in
the same vein as tokyo magnitude 2.0
which i've talked about in an older
video that i'll link on the top of the
screen japan sings 2020 kicks off with
an earthquake of insane proportions
we've always known that eventually a
giant earthquake has the chance to wreck
japan
and this netflix series takes a look at
the possibility through the lens of the
country
literally finding its way into a watery
grave it is at its core
not exactly a disaster series because
the said disasters only
set the tone for the more important
cultural themes that surface overall i
think that for something marketed as a
disaster series japan sings 2020 is
all things considered a pretty nice and
gripping show it does have its
shortcomings though while there are lots
of interesting themes a lot of them do
feel underdeveloped nevertheless
when it comes to tone and music this one
is still pretty decent
[Music]
next we move on to fog hill of five
elements for our number nine entry
non-japanese anime have been slowly
making some headway now and one of those
that's currently airing is fog hill of
five elements four kill of five elements
while having just a decent
interesting premise truly shines in its
jaw-dropping animation
unique art style and overall flair it
looks unique and stands out from what
we've been used to seeing which helps
feed into the overall enjoyment in
watching the show i feel that it does
need a lot more love than what it's
getting right now but its current status
is understandable given the lack of a
proper translation and promotion in
mainstream avenues
don't sleep on this show though it's got
some really amazing fights which got
featured in a previous video by the way
that are sure to give a lot of japanese
anime a run for their money
up next at number eight we have
uzaki-chan wants to hang out
can't get enough of dagaki-san then we
might have the next best thing for you
a nice innocent slice-of-life show
uzaki-chan wants to hang out tells the
trials and tribulations of sakura
shinichi after all
what else do you call it when all you
want is a little bit of peace and quiet
but in comes the loud underclassmen who
seemingly make a living poking fun at
you perhaps all of this teasing will
lead to something else blossoming
between the two of them
only time will tell probably more known
for the in my opinion
unjustified controversy uzaki chant is
probably on a lot of your radars i find
it a shame that the controversy had to
take precedence because on its own the
show's really relaxing it's just a fun
watch all throughout it's not deep or
complex but it doesn't need to be i
don't get tired of the main character's
antics at all and they make it a really
enjoyable combination to watch
make sure to watch this if you really
want to unwind
[Music]
making its triumphant return now with a
full uninterrupted run
is apari ranman its premise is simple
yet adventurous
no pun intended there on one hand you
have the socially awkward apare
with the goal to travel across the world
through his numerous machines and
inventions
through some twists of fate he finds
himself stranded in america with his
trusty partner the samurai kosami
left with no money or plans the two take
part in a race across the continent
promising afari the chance to showcase
his inventions and kosamay the resources
to get back home
thus the partnership between two
unlikely allies is born the show which
is
basically steel ball run in 2020 gives
us a lot of things to like
its colourful and bizarre world are
things that showcase the creativity of
anime in general
i also find the interaction between the
many characters quite entertaining to
watch
it's definitely a show that you could
enjoy
[Music]
2020 seems to be a very good year for
overpowered protagonists mahogany's
coming back in the last quarter of the
year and we have the return of kirito in
this season
sword art online airing alongside
alicization is the show
featuring the third member of the trio
of overpowered light novel protagonists
that somewhat look alike misfit
at demon king academy anas voldigold is
many things with his godlike power
that's beyond comprehension and in his
confidence he allows himself to be
killed and reincarnated 2 000 years in
the future only to wake up to a future
where history has been rewritten
and no one recognizes his status as the
demon king
even the overall power level of the
world has fallen after years of peace
however everything's but a minor
inconvenience in the face of the demon
king
that's come to retake his throne after
two millennia the era
of magic school light novels has come
full circle here and now we have
something like the one punch man of the
genre misfit's just so over the top that
it's entertaining
even for someone who's not too fond of
this genre it's just crazy to think how
far we've come to be fair in between
all of the craziness featuring the
almighty and osama misfit is an
enjoyable show with its fair share of
drama and touching moments so it's way
more than just a parody of sorts
rent a girlfriend is our number five
entry
[Music]
after getting dumped by his girlfriend
kazuya attempts to make up and fill the
void in his heart by taking
advantage of the japan classic the
rental girlfriend getting the right one
to pretend to be your girlfriend's easy
and the pretty and caring chizuru seems
to be the perfect choice for him however
things don't go as planned and with the
two having quite a rough going on their
date it seems to be a partnership
destined to do things get even more
muddled when kazuya hears of his
grandmother's collapse
and gets forced to bring chizuru along
with him not wanting to break the heart
of his grandmother who becomes overjoyed
at kazuya finally finding a serious
girlfriend kazuya and chizuru get forced
into a fake relationship
to be fair compared to the usual
rom-coms the premise of this anime does
have a different execution and i think
that rent-a-girlfriends rightfully one
of the most trending shows this season
even beating out the sequels to popular
shows at this time the main character
does get his fair share of criticism but
the hijinks and the comedy keep me
coming back on this one probably check
the first few episodes of this and see
if it's your liking
a whisker away has been through a lot
thanks to the situation of the world at
large
what was supposed to be a film ready for
theatrical release ended up becoming a
netflix offer
sometime right before the summer season
a whisker away ends up being something
you'd expect from a disney movie
but with anime characters you know the
whimsical romantic story involving magic
and transformation that we've come to
know while the story might seem quite
plain at first i think that it ended up
quite nice and heartwarming the arts
just amazing and exceptional as expected
from a full-length anime film
a whisker away is no shingai movie but i
think that it's a dramatic and
heartwarming adventure that's a good way
to spend 2 hours of your time it's a
really fun story that you can settle
down and enjoy with the family
much of the joy of fangirls worldwide
millionaire detective has made its
glorious return and likely for good the
comedy show that follows the duo of the
hilariously rich daisuke and every man
detective haru has hit the ground
running once again
the main draw of the series for me
though is the chemistry between the main
duo the two
are polar opposites and their chemistry
helps make the show very fun to watch
now i know a lot of people who find dice
gay swag and riches hilarious mean
material and i dare say that his antics
helped push the charming story just to
the next level the humor is great
the action's nice and the characters are
just so over the top that the show just
becomes
so entertaining if you've not given the
show a try from the previous season
now's the time to join the ride
in second place we have god of high
school admittedly i underestimated the
fan base for god of high school before
the season came in
i knew it was going to be popular and
for good reason too but i didn't expect
it to blow up like this as early as the
first episode does it deserve the hype
hell yeah god of high school has by all
measures a simple plot and premise cocky
high schooler thinks he's hot stuff
gets his ass kicked and starts his
journey to win the king of the iron fist
tournament
hmm i mean the god of high school yes
that's the name of the tournament along
the way
expect to see some of the coolest and
most breathtaking fight scenes this
season has to offer the show made me a
believer so early with this amazing
fight choreography and animation and i
can't wait to see
what's gonna happen next in spite of all
these things as a webtoon reader myself
i was a bit disappointed with the pacing
and the content that was cut
but after the tower of god adaptation i
guess this is something we should have
expected one of the reasons why i listed
this show in second place is because if
you don't mind the simple plot and i
hear mainly for the action this show
would probably be my top pick of the
season for you
with so many candidates i think there's
only one show that i'm gonna vote for in
the top spot
and it's decadence
entering the season i wasn't completely
sure on what to make of decadence it
seemed to have this dystopian steampunk
flair going on for it and i think that a
couple of people penciled it in as
basically another attack on titan when
the first episode hit but
boy did the show prove everyone wrong i
think that what decadence does well is
to subvert the expectations
when you have a world where monsters
have wiped out most of the people you
immediately get those attack on titan
vibes but the anime has done a good job
of throwing the twists early the show
which is made by studio nut also looks
very stylish very trigger-like and has a
lot of action-packed scenes that you've
come to know this studio for from the
second episode onwards you can see that
the show's no longer the generic monster
versus humans post-apocalyptic show
everyone made it out to be
don't sleep on decadence i'm telling you
i think it's underrated for the amount
of creativity and passion that you can
see in this thing
see challenge mode of not talking about
the numerous sequels turned up pretty
high didn't it don't you think so among
the shows listed here
what are your favorites make sure to
tell me in the comment section below and
i'll gladly have a chat with you about
them looks like the season turned out a
lot better than we expected in march now
don't you think now i wonder which of
these shows will rise further and become
anime of the season for the community
only time will tell i guess now if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
sweet like and subscribe button and i'll
be waiting for you on the next video
see ya
you